and that is my problem is we have a
bunch of women and mothers that would
rather be Instagram models than wives
and nobody tells us how stupid we look
and we should be mad at the older women
that gave us that advice and the simps
that co-signed it because the difference
is women live in delusion we don't even
know what's true and false I think
that's so obvious with with the the I'm
a 10 culture but the men they see it
they just let us do this stupid things
and nobody tells us we go through life
with these claps these co-signs where
nobody tells us what is true and what is
false and we live in this delusion for a
lifetime and the people that have to
suffer are the children